[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
20th episode of my chest strap series in
this episode I'm going to show you her
interesting trap in the French the Rask
clothes variation from the black respect
to you the opening arises after the
following model evil a 6 d 4 D 5 and now
the typical trash move Knight to D 2 the
idea is if black plays Bishop to b4 then
c3 and white can easily unpin the noid
so that's why the mainline runs with
move Knight to f6 pressurizing the e4 e5
grabbing the space in the center and
after Knight F to d7 we dish to the
typical French defense structure where
as a black you want to quickly place
afar and undermine the white pawn chain
and on the counter power white wants to
put his pieces actively and look for the
King side attack the ship to d3 c5 and
now c3 consolidating the center black
obviously pressurize the d4 square with
Knight to c6 and white plays Knight to
e2 this move is more logical as I have
highlighted over here later on white has
good night maneuvering which helped to
create King side attack ok at this point
black exchange in the center C captures
d4c captures d4 and now played this
traumatic break up 6 which undermines
the white center at this position as I
have highlighted over here why it should
continue with either Knight to f4 or
ECAP to sep 6 which is completely fine
but when I check this position in online
database I found out that here there are
more than 350 games continue with f4 and
some of them are very recent
unfortunately for white this is not an
accurate move and this leads to our
trappy line black should continue with
EPP captures ePHI and now white has two
choices let's look at first of all what
happens if you open and continue 8f kept
us ePHI which is more natural in this
position but this leads to straight away
into our dark trap tunnel can you spot
blacks next more yes it's very obvious
and thematic BAM so just with intent
move of the game black Vince the porn
and okay black has to know some accurate
sequence after this but overall later on
this extra porn do comes white has tried
two options here but none of them work
very well
the first response we need to know what
happens if white take this piece and
captures d4 when after that the coin
check and obviously after g3 black is
going to regain the piece but white can
argue that he has some initiative with
Knight to f3
so black need to play some careful moves
to consolidate his advantage now Bishop
to b4 is the most popular choice here
however it's inaccurate due to the king
of fun so my recommendation is here
black should continue with Queen to b6
and after some accurate response such as
Queen to c2 attacking on at 7 g6
defending king to have fun so King is
heading towards to g2 square which is
very safe after that black should
immediately attack the bishop with
Knight to c5
Bishop to e3 pinning down the night and
then Queen to b4 indeed threatening
Knight captures d3 so it needs to
preserve the bishop pair with Bishop to
e2 but that allows Knight to e4 and that
Knight is wonderfully placed at the
center of the volley fortunately I
reached this position against the
national master in a five minute game
and I think this game is a model
demonstration how black can continue
from here
white continue with King to g2 I
continue with Bishop to d7 and now my
opponent played Luke h2 7 ok as I have
seen no threats I continue with Bishop
to g7 and my opponent played a very
tricky move Queen to b3 well I was more
than happy to exchange the Queen because
after Queen takes pawn takes okay I have
some pressures but I think I can easily
neutralized as after a 6
my opponent revealed his nasty idea that
is Fructis e7 attacking on b7 it is just
a matter of consolidation
so I played rook to b8 and my opponent
double up on the save file so at first
sight it looks somewhat threatening but
after blacks next reply that is King to
e7 I think black is a healthy pawn up
and there is hardly any compensation for
the white he played Bishop to d3
I played Luke H to c8 and here we both
were in the time terrible and I think he
miscalculated because what he played is
rook captures rook captures rook
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
efore pawn captures efore and now Knight
to g5 which at first sight looks so
impressive because not only its regained
the pawn but it attacked the two sports
but after the following sequence that is
Bishop captures ePHI Knight captures at
7 the ship captures b2 Knight to g5
so white is trying to gain his pawn back
but in that process he forgot that after
the move beef I Knight captures efore
and Bishop to b7 it's a game over time
because after King to have three and a
fi my opponent simply resign because not
only black is a clear point up but
there's a monster pawn running on the
e-file which is not easy to stop on the
second try by white here is castle on
the King side but this is hardly a good
option because after Queen to b6 black
is already looking to give a discover
check so white response is almost forced
he has to play King to h1 and after that
we can simply play Knight captures if I
grabbing the second pawn and ask him why
are you serious about your business okay
Knight captures d4 Queen captures d4
Bishop to b5 check Bishop to d7 Bishop
captures d7 and at this point black need
to be careful as after Knight captures
b7 Queen to h5 check is a very deadly
reply so black has to capture with the
King and after Knight to f3 Knight
captures f3 Queen captures f3 and Bishop
to e7 yes of course White has managed to
keep blacking in the center but to pawn
I don't think so that is enough
compensation black can easily regroup
his position and later on this extra to
Center pawns are the winning asset for
the black I have attached a model game
in this position which will give you a
very good idea how to play as a black in
this position
last but not least what happens if your
opponent captured with the D pawn well
in this case the straightforward
advantage is black immediately get the
bishop pair after night to c5 a bishop
to b1 then Queen to b6 and white cannot
castle so as per the engine the best
reply here is Bishop to c2 but after
that black can continue with Knight to
be full and now Bishop to be one is not
a possibility due to the knight chair so
base reply is castle on the King side
afterwards we can simply take this
bishop and after Queen takes Queen to b6
King to h1 and Bishop to e7 black
obtained a bishop pair and as the light
square Bishop is exchanged there is no
danger on the Kings side
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this nasty trap in the trash with
night captures D fall and after this
however a white plays it's only black
who is in the driver's seat and with
some accurate play you can easily
convert into the full point thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care